bonjour merci d'être avec nous alors
c'est évident boris johnson à paris de
plus en plus fragilisé on peut dire que
les toujours c'est au tour de mary j ça
c'est évident et que ces heures sont
peut-être comptés mais il faut pas
sous-estimer non plus le personnage
pourra être demandé quelqu'un qui a
aussi l'habitude de rebondir mais c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui il est dans une
situation très délicate délicate
pourquoi parce que le parti conservateur
a changé et le parti conservateur peut
ne pas faire de cadeaux comme il n'a pas
fait de cadeau d'ailleurs à une certaine
époque avec une certaine margaret
thatcher voire même plus récemment avec
theresa may qui avait pourtant gagné des
élections et qui s'est fait éjecter du
parti de down et serez tout ça parce que
ont jugé qu'elle était incapable de
mener à bien les négociations du break
site donc vori johnson lui c'est pas sur
ce thème là laissez bien sûr ses
mensonges sur sa manière finalement de
dissimuler des réalités qui apparaissent
de plus en plus évidente notamment
toutes ces réunions à downing street qui
ont considérablement nui à sa
crédibilité
alors que va-t-il se passer actuellement
il y a eu une enquête qui est menée par
scotland yard par la police pour savoir
exactement qui est la réalité des fêtes
donc tout est un peu soumis aux
résultats de cette enquête à tel point
que le haut fonctionnaire qui avait
chargé notamment de faire ses premières
révélations s'est replié à accepter
finalement de s'en remettre aux
résultats de cette enquête on devrait
connaître dans les prochains jours
d'autant que cette enquête n'a pas été
publié ben johnson espère effectivement
convaincre la plupart de ses collègues
de tenir et de tenir coûte que coûte
c'est pas facile parce que je le disais
tout à l'heure le parti conservateur a
changé et que ce parti conservateur est
beaucoup plus large qu'avant il est à la
fois plus large et plus jeune il y à
hautmont parti conservateur qu'une
frange de nouveaux députés qui ont été
élus notamment dans le nord de
l'angleterre dans des bastions qui était
travailliste à l'origine ces jeunes
députés almir et azmir la soupe de ben
johnson et son prêt finalement à le
soutenir et donc il faut pas
sous-estimer ses appuis que maurice
joseph pluta voix au sein même des
jeunes députés conservateurs
britanniques voilà qui met finalement la
perspective difficile l'étau se resserre
autour de ben johnson mais je pense
qu'il n'a pas encore déclaré son dernier
mot alors vous le disais il ya une
enquête de police qui est toujours en
cours il ya eu un rapport qui a été
publié et le mea culpa de boris johnson
se met à compas justement vous en avez
pensé quoi
mais le problème du mea culpa c'est
comme le problème de la vérité du
mensonge en politique de plus en plus
vous voyez bien dans quelle époque nous
vivons actuellement dans lequel les
faits qst finalement ne sont plus
tellement un obstacle dans la
réalisation de la politique et bien
aujourd'hui pour certains députés pour
certaines personnes finalement le fait
de mentir n'est pas forcément si mauvais
que ça en politique c'est peut-être
déplorable mais les choses en sont ainsi
et donc comme johnson est quelqu'un qui
est extrêmement dynamique qui est
quelqu'un qui a beaucoup de ressorts bah
finalement c'est son ressort que l'on
admire plus que c'est ce qu'il peut dire
aussi qu'il peut cacher il s'est
probablement ça qui pour l'instant
assure sa défense ce qui est réel et
qu'on peut tenir un moment en cachant
une certaine manière de la vérité on
peut pas tenir très longtemps dans ce
système là surtout dangereux un pays
comme l'angleterre alors on parle même
d'un vote de défiance au parlement vous
en pensez quoi c'est possible 54 il
suffit que 54 députés conservateurs
finalement décide de franchir le pas et
de demander un vote de défiance devant
et je sens et vous savez c'est un espèce
de clubs le privé plus club de
conservateurs qui une fois qu'il a 54
demande de vote pour une des futures
démission du premier ministre
6 si ce vote est concluant et s'il
aboutit effectivement la demande de
démission du premier ministre celui ci
est obligé d'aimer chirez mais si par
exemple le le vote est négatif avec le
vote maintient la confiance dans le
premier ministre et bien les
conservateurs sont obligés d'attendre un
an avant de procéder à un nouveau vote
donc tout cela fait que les
conservateurs actuellement
avant d'engager cette arme suprême de
7,7 armes atomiques je dirais
réfléchisse à deux fois c'est pour ça
effectivement que pour l'instant il est
un certain temps avant de décider
d'engager cette arme fatale et ouais
rien est encore joué en tout cas
françois pour les mathis merci d'avoir
été avec moi je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste spécialiste des institutions
européennes merci d'avoir été en direct
sur rt france